you want a piece of me for a long time
alright time for the newest edition of
Crowder confronts as you all know our
first choice in this channel is civil
debate as seen with the countless change
my mind videos and long-form guests
every now and then when it comes to
threats of violence or calls to action
for violent behavior people need to be
called on their crap
take for instance Mac has a long and
storied history of violence from simply
voicing support for antiphon the act of
punching Nazis - more emphatic
declarative statements like the fact
that we need to quote kill every member
of ice which could see my per Baalak I
know until you see that he doubled down
while actively confirming that he would
front 500 dollars for anyone who kills a
member of ice he's wanted a piece of me
for a long time
his words luckily for me mu he was
staging a protest in Texas with a few
attendees and he was going to make it
happen rain or shine except he cancelled
these guys are a disgrace fortunately
for us we had his private phone number
because he gave it out publicly on his
petition that no one's signed and with
some quick thinking and a little
super-secret spy work to do well there
may be some restaurant or something
maybe we could get a beer beer garden
can't help with the killing of innocent
officers but cook if you've wanted a
piece of me for a long time well now
you're down to two wishes
you want to piece me for a long time old
yeah it's true he attempted to throw a
drink on me which felt incredibly
familiar but also ill-fitting for some
reason we want asking people to kill
members of ice how about that five
hundred dollars ahead come on man you
gonna start even wanted a piece of me
for a long time so I'm gonna do it throw
some Pilsner I would never advocate
violence
I completely condemn any violence at all
it's not what this is about well I'm
find that you've wanted a piece of me
for a long time I want to know what that
was they're just talking do we have a
conversation so what did you what did
you mean by that with it like what you
meant with killing members of ice for
$500 a pop you don't but hold on a
second quarter black we've got a bristol
board you want to kill Betsy DeVos right
kill ice slytherin that's glorious it's
always a sign of a tough tough guy on
the Internet kill ice kill every member
of ice and then that you will help fund
$500 for every member of ice killed you
think that's okay
because you know I didn't do that you
said a friend almost died because of me
I've never once advocated violence
against someone else like this matter of
fact I've condemned it if you just say
it was keyboard warrior talk you know
from wherever you are a laptop that's
fine it could be the end of it take it
down take down the threats take down the
offers to pay people for killing other
people and that'll be it but if not
we're going to file this with the police
ok I'm sure they're gonna be thrilled to
see killed open pigs five hundred
dollars a head for ice come on man
here's your chance
everyone's gonna see this future people
hiring you members of ice police
officers well I mean I guess you all
think I'm an unemployed well I don't
know I don't know that you're not
employed leftist are you he didn't
follow through on your own protest
there's the only thing you follow
through on violence nothing nothing all
right I'm gonna ask you one left and
I'll just I'll leave you that's fine
next stop is the police station okay all
right that's the next stop enjoy your
night
as always our first choice is civil
discourse in this channel but if you
cross the line into violence or if you
call for the physical harm of others I
will find you I will report you I will
confront and I will shame you like this
video watch another one of our videos or
subscribe at the notification bell those
don't really mean anything anymore today
in YouTube I would say hit a like with a
thumbs up but that might be gone or
comment below but that most likely will
be censored so bookmark the page of
course if you're using Google Chrome
they'll find a way to [ __ ] with your
bookmark so just join up at la doors
Crider comm slash mug club that's a lot
of credit come slash mug club you get a
hand at schmuck and you get access to
the full daily one-hour show and you're
not beholden to Susan Wojcicki slash
Clint Howard